With more states and localities
legalizing drugs.
How should we rethink criminal
penalties and treatment for people
with substance abuse problems?
What policy and cultural frameworks
will allow all of us to make better
use decisions, reduce
harms to ourselves and others, and
make sure people who need help can
get it? That was the subject of the
Reason Speakeasy, held on January
4th at the Blue Building in New York
City. The Speakeasy is a monthly
unscripted conversation with
outspoken defenders of free speech
and heterodox thinking that
doubles as a live taping of the
Reason Interview podcast.
The guest for psychologist Andrew
Tatarsky, the founder of the
Center for Optimal Living and
author of "Harm Reduction
Psychotherapy: A New Treatment
for Drug and Alcohol Problems"
and Maia Szalavitz,
the author of "Undoing Drugs The
Untold Story of Harm Reduction
and the Future of Addiction
and Unbroken Brand of
Revolutionary New Way of
Understanding Addiction."
What's the definition of the concept
of harm reduction when it comes to
drug policy?
Sure. So it's basically the idea
that we should focus on stopping
people from getting hurt rather than
stopping them from getting high.
And that sounds really simple
and obvious, but our policy
has historically and
continues to focus
on stopping drugs,
stopping drug use,
not even stopping addiction,
but just stopping these substances.
Which, of course leaves out
why people do them
and what people get out of them.
And the fact that since
before humans evolved into humans,
animals have been getting high.
Cats have catnip.
We can all name things that
other species have used, and
every single human culture
historically has had
some kind of psychoactive thing.
So the idea that you could actually
stop people from getting high rather
than stopping certain people
from using substances you don't like
because you want to oppress them
is ridiculous.
So
we're going to talk about the
origins of harm reduction in a
minute. But could you talk a little
bit about where
did the prohibitionist
mindset come from or
was is harm reduction a
return to an earlier understanding
of how people should be using drugs
or how policy should treat them?
I mean, there certainly are
precursors historically to harm
reduction and particularly in the
sixties and seventies.
There were kind of nascent ideas
and they probably even use the term
the term itself
as a drug policy
term comes from
Liverpool in 1987
and a guy named Russell Newcombe,
who was himself a user of
stimulants, and
he and a bunch of other people
realized that in Liverpool,
basically they had a lot of
youth unemployment, like 50%
deindustrialization, massive
amounts of injection drug use.
Now, up the road, 200 miles
in Edinburgh, they had
massive unemployment, lots of
youth drug use and
50% of the users
were already HIV infected when
they first got an HIV
test.
Liverpool, however, had no HIV
at this point among drug users,
and so they were like,
If we don't do something, this is
going to happen.
And we know quite well
that we are not going to be able to
stop everybody from injecting
immediately.
And they
basically decided the
Thatcher government actually made
the statement that HIV
is a more serious threat to public
health than drug use.
And so we should prioritize
things accordingly.
In the United States, we decided to
ban federal funding for needle
exchange.
But I have to say now
the UK's drug policy is worse
than ours and worse...
Alright. America's number one again.
It's really bizarre. But anyway.
But your men's soccer team
may be on par.
Andrew, could you talk
how how do you talk about harm
reduction at the Center for Optimal
Living in particular?
But, you know, if somebody comes in
and says, you know, I hear about
this harm reduction, what does that
mean?
Well, for me, the
central shift, the primary
shift from traditional
treatments which have been dominated
by an abstinence only
framework.